what would you tell a younger after
seeking an agent before you approach an
agent about representing you put
yourself in the agents shoes and have
empathy for them and understand that if
they say no it's nothing personal
this will also help you understand what
the agent may be looking for the only
reason that an agent's going to be
interested in you is if they think they
can make money off of you understand
that it's not about whether they like
you or not it's whether you as a
commodity can make them money if it's a
good fit and they'll be very interested
in you if they think they can make money
off you so when you make your approach
to them why are you marketable you know
what about you makes you special or
different from any other actor in your
category know those things and don't be
afraid to say them and to ask for the
sale to end the conversation by saying
reiterating those points by saying you
know Karen I would really like to be
associated with your agency because ABC
which are the same things you said at
the beginning it's a business sales call
so this hypothetical young actor is
going to meet for an agent the first
time yes what are they doing the day
leading up to days leading up and then
once they get to the old treated like an
audition which means you are going to be
early you're going to be well prepared
you are already going to have had the
conversation in your head so many times
that you're absolutely comfortable
you're never flummoxed you're going to
wear something that you feel really
comfortable in and that morning you're
gonna do something that you really love
to do and have plenty of time to get
there that's so important in LA do not
ever be rush because it'll show in your
face and then when you get there listen
when I had my agent meeting for the
agent that I just signed with the she
didn't ask me very many questions mostly
I listen because if you're sitting
across the desk from an agent they've
already done their due diligence they've
done their homework you don't have to
impress them they'll ask you what they
want to know of you what they really
want to know is they want to look into
your eyes and say can I trust you and
you trust me
it sounds like that's a really
interesting tip and a very big part of
what you do is getting your mind set in
a great place
before you go somewhere understand that
as an actor you're an entertainer and
your job is to entertain even if you're
meeting with an agent you want it to be
a pleasant encounter for them you want
them to feel uplifted you want their day
to be brighter even when you're doing an
audition before you begin the audition
you're an entertainer I don't mean you
sing and dance but one of the best tips
I ever got was say your name when you
come in the room so come in the audition
room and instead of standing there
looking for my ex I say hey guys I'm
bill Oberst jr. that's it it changes the
atmosphere of the room it makes
everybody kind of brighten up or smile a
little bit you're always an entertainer
if you're an actor and your job is not
to or be concerned about yourself
your job is to lift other people up
that's what an entertainer does we lift
people up and we make their days
brighter an entertainer is a servant I
think that's a good mentality to have so
you're not what if you have to do your
taxes and you know that you have to be
there or just something that's just
painful will you schedule it for another
time just so you spend 15 minutes
listening to music doing push-ups yes
and going to sort of happy because if
you don't you'll be filled with
self-pity and self-pity is anathema to
an actor you'll never book if you
because they'll feel it they'll smell it
you need to be confident and successful
if there's something unpleasant that you
have to do yeah try not to do it the day
that you have an audition or you have a
meeting with an agent or any type of
interaction this morning when I got out
before you I talked to you guys I made
myself turn the computer off for an hour
before I came here and it was really
hard because I thought of a lot of
things I could do online I said no I
don't want to get there and I don't want
to be in this busy busy mindset I really
want to be able to relate as a human
being and look in someone's eyes and
talk because that's the part of our job
too as well as staring at that screen
you